bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation le protêt de charlie hebdo
fait de l'hyper cacher s'ouvre donc cinq
ans après les faits on parle de la
défaite de dave sur de nombreux
territoires du moyen-orient mais qu'en
est il en france est-ce que la menace
terroriste est toujours aussi
persistante
la menace est toujours persistante les
probablement moins fort qu'il y a cinq
ans la mise sur pied d'une opération
quasi militaire avec des gens armés
regrouper genre coulibaly ou à faire du
bataclan ça reste vraiment très très
limité mais la menace est là non
seulement le procureur antiterroriste a
rappelé récemment qu'une dizaine
d'attentats avaient été déjoués en
france ces derniers mois
il faut quand même rappeler que depuis
le début de l'année il ya eu quatre
actions individuelles qui ont entraîné
des morts dans l'isère villejuif à metz
donc des actions individuelles certes
mais avec des individus fanatisés qui
passent à l'acte et qui n'hésite pas à
poignarder a tué deux de ces attentats
ont eu lieu pendant la période de
confinement oui la menace est toujours
là
la france est une cible privilégiée par
les djihadistes pourquoi
la france est une cible privilégiée
alors l'europe dans son ensemble l'a été
dans le passé mais nous nous restons
toujours une cible privilégiée tout
simplement parce que la france s'est
engagée au moyen-orient comme en afrique
dans la lutte contre le djihadisme
c'est donc une bonne raison pour ces
terroristes de s'attaquer à la france
pour se venger en riposte à nos actions
militaires
et puis il ya aussi il faut l'observer
il faut le dire une montée de la
radicalisation en france qui favorise
après le passage à l'acte à l'acte
terroriste alors plus de 8000 personnes
sont fichées pour eux radicalisation à
caractère terroriste en france les
chiffres communiqués en début de semaine
par le ministre de l'intérieur qu'est ce
que ça veut dire précisément qu'il
s'agit d' éventuels terroristes à venir
alors ça c'est l'éternel débat est ce
que ceux qui sont fichés affiché est
fiché fanatisés sont des terroristes
potentiels
on ne sait pas on peut le supposer ça
veut dire qu'ils sont normalement
surveiller le vrai sujet c'est que ces
gens là peuvent se passer à l'acte
à tout moment sans avoir été pour autant
ficher tous ceux qui en france ont
commis des attentats ces dernières
années n'était pas forcément fiche et s6
chez terroriste parce que vous avez dans
le comportement de ces individus une
part de fanatisme une part d'adhésion à
la religion islamique
ce qu'on appelle les fous de dieu plus
que jamais on peut les appeler de ce nom
mais parfois le passage à l'acte qui se
fait de façon spontanée totalement
inattendu imprévisible et un individu
qui n'est pas si chez s&p tués
c'était le cas par exemple à
saint-etienne du rouvray
quand les deux individus ont assassiné
le père hamel ils n'étaient pas fichés
où l'un des deux n'était pas fiché est
ce une quarantaine de détenus condamnés
pour des infractions à caractère
terroriste vont être relâchés cette
année ils seront soixante trois ans en
2021 est ce qu'ils vont faire
et d'après vous l'objet d'une
surveillance accrue même après avoir
purgé leur peine
alors je crois que là effectivement
c'est un vrai sujet sensible gravissime
qui sera entre les mains du gouvernement
et notamment du ministère de la justice
du ministère de l'intérieur
les surveiller et ben oui je pense
qu'ils le seront je ne peux pas imaginer
un seul instant qu'il ne le soit pas
mais seriez ça veut dire quoi
ils vont bien évidemment se méfier de
leurs téléphones de leurs moyens de
communication pensant qu'ils seront
probablement mis sur écoute
mais après dans la vie de tous les jours
on pourra pas mettre 24 heures sur 24
des dizaines et des centaines de
policiers derrière ces individus qui
vous savez une filature sa seront ou
saas interrompt un individu qui
considèrent qu'il est surveillé
physiquement peut très bien déjouer des
filatures et monthey nouveau des
opérations non curat à mettre sur pied
effectivement des mesures de
surveillance mais surmonter l'efficace
seul l'avenir nous le dira souvent de
laxisme judiciaire face au terrorisme
est-ce que la réponse aujourd'hui est
suffisamment adapté ou est-ce qu'il faut
davantage durcir les peines selon vous
alors tout d'abord la législation permet
des peines sévères
ça c'est le premier point et d'une façon
générale si on met en perspective les
affaires de terrorisme jugées en france
depuis 30 ans qu'il s'agisse de
l'extrême gauche qu'il s'agisse
d'anciens groupes terroristes de
l'époque d'abou nidal ou bref d'une
façon générale au moment du procès la
justice a toujours fait preuve d'une
très grande fermeté ça on ne peut pas le
contester avec des condamnations de
réclusion à perpétuité
prenons le cas des gens d'action directe
ils ont été condamné deux fois à
perpétuité
et puis ceux qui en 95 avec le gia avait
commis des attentats en france métro
saint-michel port royal ont été
également condamnés à perpétuité le
problème après c'est l'exécution de la
peine
on observe par exemple que celui qui en
83 avait tué un arménien plus de quinze
personnes et des centaines de blessés
à orly a été libéré au bout de sept ans
action directe ils ont été libérés au
bout de 25 ans certains de ceux qui ont
commis les attentats de 95 sont déjà
dehors c'est donc dans l'exécution de la
peine à mon avis qu'il faudrait être un
peu plus ferme
rené georges querry ce merci pour cet
éclairage je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien chef de l'unité de coordination
de lutte antiterroriste merci beaucoup